hey everybody its Jesse and today I'm
sick so I apologize if I'm a little bit
harder to hear today or a little out of
it but I don't have time to be sick
because we got to launch this site so
the site's going to launch tomorrow we
need to do some testing I'm going to
test using browser stack and also with
the device so I have the pixel XL and
I'm just I have it connected directly to
my iMac and we're going to use dev tools
and test on the device I did want to
show you how to test simulate an iPhone
with Xcode but I tried to start it two
minutes ago and it wanted me to download
extra stuff for it to work that's not
going to happen so sorry about that
ideally for it it's better if you
actually have a fun and iPhone to test
it on if you can get a hold of one I
found the simulator isn't always
accurate you get the Xcode simulator so
some other people that I work with have
fun so I'm just going to borrow one of
their funds later on and test because
based on the analytics for some of our
other sites a lot of users are going to
be on an iPhone so the browsers that we
need to worry about most based on the
analytics are chrome which we should be
fine in chrome we've been developing it
in from the whole way so I'm not as
worried about that and Safari
specifically Mobile Safari which I
always have problems with on my list of
least favorite browsers Mobile Safari
might be worse than edited Explorer for
me so I mean at least worse than
Internet Explorer 11 we will try out
internet explorer 11
I don't think I'm going to bother with
edge because our analytics show it's
such a small percentage of our users are
using edge it's probably not a good use
of our time at this point if I had more
time I'd maybe give it a try so let's
get started with some testing oh hey
everybody I just looked at the live chat
some people saying hello I've a question
for it for all of you if I'm having an
issue with one of my other site so I'm
going to throw this out there and y'all
can think about it and comment or direct
message me or something if you have a
good answer I'm using I have an app
where users have to log in I'm using
auth0 for authentication it's one of the
magic link logins so they get an email
with a link when they click the link
they're logged in and it saves
everything in the browser's local
storage and they're supposed to stay
logged in unless they actually log
themselves out with the log out button
so I'm having two problems one users
keep getting logged out and they're
saying that they haven't tried to log
out they can't remember what they can't
remember ever like running some type of
program that would have logged them out
like cleared out all their local storage
so basically they're getting logged out
for no apparent reason and I haven't
been able to recreate the issue
I've tried probably dozens of times have
gone to the you know different computers
that the actual computers where it's
happening for the users and I can't get
it to happen again and then the other
issue is when they try to log back in
and have that that magic link sent to
them again they're not seeing the emails
I'm using SendGrid for emails and the
SendGrid analytics it says that the
emails are actually delivered but
they're not they're not showing up in
their inbox or in the junk mail folders
for these people so just just one of
anyone
using either SendGrid or r0 or both of
them together if you've had any issues
like that especially issues with local
storage being cleared out randomly from
the browser or with emails some some
people just not getting emails on the
same system I'm on the same email system
and I tested it earlier I got the email
within a minute
so I don't the issues so sorry for the
little sidebar there let's get back to
the testing so basically the first thing
I want to do is show you how to set up
the a mobile device for testing so
there's not a lot you have to do
actually on the phone so I'm not going
to show you the phone part of it but you
can look it up it's usually it's pretty
easy you'd have to go into your settings
under your advanced settings and there's
like a developer mode I think you have
to click on the version number in
settings like seven times
it's really weird I'm this is for
Android by the way so I you can hook up
an iPhone and do debugging as well but
it's a different since I don't have an
iPhone right now I'm not going to go
over that maybe we'll do it in a
different video so basically you have to
enable developer options and you do that
by I can't remember exactly what you
clicked I've already done it but I think
it's like the Android version number
when you go into settings and about and
you have to click it I think seven times
and then will ask you do want to enable
developer options yes and then you have
this extra thing in your menu this extra
item so you can go into there and enable
USB debugging so that's what you want
you want to be able to enable USB
debugging so if you haven't Android you
want to do this Google enable USB
debugging on and
and it will let you know exactly what
the steps are since I camera I'm almost
positive that the way I described it is
how it went but it's been so long since
I've done it I can't be sure so you
probably want to double-check I don't
have a link right now so sorry if I if I
have time and I remember which I
probably want I'll throw the link in the
description normally I would throw the
link in but I'm just really pressed for
time to get this site launched so now
I'm going to show you how to link up
your device so if you open up dev tools
okay which you can just click on inspect
anywhere and that will open up dev tools
for you
let me how's the font on dev tools do I
need to make it bigger let me know
alright somebody in a live chat said
it's not the Android version number it's
the compilation number or something like
that I think you're right I can't
remember it was some some number in
there I know that's not great
information but I'm you'll be able to
find it the information is really easy
to find if you want like a step by step
if you go to Udacity they actually show
you this in in one of their courses they
have like a link to a video it's their
course on my like mobile is a responsive
images something like that sorry that's
not good advice I think so let me make
this bigger and move this up here so you
can see what's going on okay so we have
some of the live chat saying we do need
it bigger okay that's probably as big as
I can make it without blocking out stuff
that we need to see so all I've done is
I've connected my my phone to the
computer so I have for this phone it's
one of the USBC
so I have a connector that's just a
regular USB on one end and then a new
USBC on the other end going into my
phone so that's plugged in I've enabled
USB debugging on my phone now I just
open dev tools and I go I click on this
it probably will be clicked on by
default discover USB devices when I do
that then it brings up this pixel so I
can see it over here and I'll actually
if you click it it will show you open
windows that you have I've done one
other steps since we're developing this
locally if you're not testing a site
locally if you're testing a site that's
available you know online from a normal
URL you can skip this step but since we
have a local server running we want to
match up the ports so I just used
localhost 8080 this first number is for
my phone the second one is what port
we're running it on so I'm actually
running this local server on port 3000
so I just I added a rule when I entered
these two numbers in now when I go on my
phone to localhost 8080 I can actually
see the development side I know you guys
can't see it I was trying to I have a
program there let me share my phone
screen but for some reason it wasn't
working I kind of think that because I'm
using the ports it's like one of the
ports that that was also using and so I
messed it up but I didn't really have
time to troubleshoot so now that you're
linked up you can go I can go into my
pixel and see I have been saying the
port forwarding is working and I want to
inspect let's enter URL so you can I can
enter this localhost 8080 and click open
and this should work okay I guess not
there we go it just took a second but
see it on my phone it just opened it and
now I can see that tab here that
localhost:8080 and now I can it inspect
okay and now my inspector it's taking a
second to load but now this section once
it loads this section will actually
correspond to what's on my phone so the
cool thing is now if I go over and
change some Styles here it'll show up on
my phone in real time so I can test it
out it's a little bit nicer than just
kind of shrinking your window because
you get to you'll really see like how if
you have let's say some type of scroll
tracking or click function or something
you can see how it is with the touch I
know you can simulate some of this with
dev tools but if you have a device you
don't have to have every device if you
just get one device and try things out
on it it's really worthwhile so in
general I just you know click around and
see see what's working what's not
working so there's definitely some delay
so just a heads-up on that every time I
go to click on a link it doesn't refresh
right away there's this a delay so
alright so I'm not going to spend a lot
of time on that I just wanted to show
you how to set that up because I didn't
get the screen sharing working so it'd
be really boring for you all to have me
describe to you what I'm saying on my
mobile the next way I'm going to test is
with browser stacks
I have this somewhere where did I put it
okay here it is okay so we have thanks
for the ports it sorry I'm just checking
the live chat for a second make sure
okay it looks like there's we don't have
any questions or anything everybody's
still following alright so I'm going to
go in here in a browser stack now I can
I normally just use Xcode since I'm on a
Mac and I test directly on my Mac
instead of going in to a browser stack
but since I have have to install updates
before that'll work let's go in we'll
just try this iPhone 6's I don't have a
lot of like really good analytics data
on the actual type of iPhone devices
exercise I don't know my screen is maybe
27 I sorry I just lost my train of
thought if you're just joining in you
missed at the beginning I apologize in
advance I'm really not feeling well so
the the streams going to be a little bit
a little bit off I'm just not going to
be as as on top of things as I normally
would be so you have to wait this is
browser stack is it's pretty good hey
this is it actually saved the last site
I looked at on here probably not me this
is a somebody we share an account me and
another developer so that's probably
it's like he was testing so basically I
I have a phone here I don't know if I
can make this bigger so I'm sorry if
this is small it looks small for me so
I'll just give you kind of an idea of
how to do this
now some things on browserstack allow
you to do port forwarding last time I
use this which is within the last few
months you could not do it with the
iPhones so I'm not going to try to do it
right now
you can do it I think with Windows based
things windows-based browsers so you
might want to check that out that would
also be cool so in this case I'm just
going to go to our test you are out and
it's it's pretty much up to date there's
a couple of things I did that I didn't
push to the to the server yet but for
the most part test code catechins calm
let's see okay it's not it's not working
let me go back here and see if it's
working on on my brother okay wow it is
working let me refresh one more son good
thing we're testing let's try to go to
maybe one of the interior pages see if
we have a better look No
all right now we can't open dev tools
here so let's open dev tools and see
what we're getting
can't find variable and it's unexpected
NFR this card hmm
all right let's see where this is that
it's possible it's not showing me hmm
let's see I want to go and shovel it
looks like it's not even loading I want
to check to make sure okay it is loading
our our app all right dodge it is okay
okay it's linked two of them all right
so what did it say 121 this this card
team card clickhandler okay
yeah the lab says somebody asks is
browserstack free there is a free trial
it doesn't let you do a lot though so
yeah this is not a free tool yeah you
can use Xcode to simulate an iPhone on
your computer for free if you have a Mac
so I would normally I like to use that
better than trying to simulate iPhones
and browserstack and then if you have a
device the actual physical device of
course you can test with that but I
think probably what's happening with the
iPhone and I'll need to I'm going to
test this with an actual device just so
it's a little bit faster for me after I
update Xcode probably what's happening
and I don't know why this just slipped
my mind before is I'm using a lot of
things from es6 I don't know what the
coverage is on mobile safari for es6
it's possible that that's messing some
of this this up
I don't know we'll see yeah because the
first the first time I use something
that's es6 is at line 21 and I'm using
let instead of their and that's the
first error we got so I'm guessing
Mobile Safari does not support let so
I'll have to use Babel and transpile
that into es5 code and then try again on
an iPhone but what we can do is try to
go I don't think I have a page that
isn't using some type of es6 we can
transpile real quick and do it I mean we
have that might be worthwhile worthwhile
to do so if you've never used es6 or
babel before let's try it out okay so
you need to let's see let me grab all of
my app touches so basically this
JavaScript that you're writing in your
components you're fine with it's going
to be automatically transpired but since
we imported this a tas file from our
previous static site then we just
brought it in and have it in the static
folder i next doesn't automatically
transpile that for you that's something
I'd have to set up probably as an NPM
script in the package.json file so I
have not set that up yet I've set it up
in a previous project at some point I'm
probably just going to copy that code
into there but I haven't done it yet so
what we can do now is just kind of
manually transpile this just so that we
can do some testing so I just copy this
in on this side and you can see
using let me make this bigger I'll make
this whole thing bigger okay so on this
side we have some es6 stuffs we have let
what else we have I'm probably using
cost in some places too I'm using
template literal syntax so we go over to
this side we can see that let has been
changed into two there and I'm not going
to look for the template literal syntax
but if you basically what it would do is
just use regular quotation marks and you
know your plus signs mix in with your
variables so your file is going to be a
little bit bigger after you do this but
older browsers will be able to use it so
I'm just going to copy this for now and
[Music]
let's see what the best way to do this I
I'm just going to I'm just going to go
and paste this all in and overwrite this
file for now because we have this this
saves the lemming let me just throw this
in another file just to say that okay
just in case we need to go back
okay so let's save and we're going to go
over I'm going to put this on the server
really quick it should take probably two
minutes - I'll let you guys see this I
showed everybody yesterday but just in
case you don't know how I'm putting
things on the server right now this is
the tooth let's make this a bit bigger
okay so this is my local machine I'm
just going to do a git commit
so we're just going to transpile we're
going to push that to github and then
let's go back here I've just used SSH to
go into the server on digital ocean and
now I'm in to see them it looks
different a username Jessie now we're
going to go into our folder and we're
going to stop stop our our app for just
a minute we'll do a get pool and we'll
do we'll do a build as soon as this
builds over we'll just start up our
server again and then we're good to go
with our testing we go right back in now
we shouldn't get the errors from the ESX
stuff so so I didn't think of that
beforehand just working on a lot of
other stuff today and I did not think
about it okay so Patrick and a live chat
says can I use as mobile safari should
support let since late last year okay
well I'm not sure what the problem was
then I mean we're definitely getting an
error on the the line that I first used
let with so I'm not actually I don't
remember what version of Safari I was
testing with browser stack it's possible
that I was testing an older version
we'll go back in and see what the
version is all right so now our build is
ready let me start everything up and we
should be good to go so let's go back
over here and let's try oops let's try
to go back all right
and it works so
I'm not sure what what the problem was
for sure I think it was let and this is
probably just an older version of Safari
but now at least we can scroll down let
me see if I can make this bigger hmm all
right since device is already to actual
size so I guess it's not okay so this is
browsers iOS 9 so this is Safari in an
iOS version 9 what's the newest one is
it is 10
okay so nice you gather you already
uncovered in the live chat support for 4
let which is an es6 thing starts in
version 10.2 ok and somebody mentions
something about the auth0 stuff I don't
want to interrupt right now so towards
the end I'm going to come back to that
thanks for for mentioning that I'll just
say for now I'm not using an iframe to
log out on the log out is basically I
just clear local storage when they click
the button but people are saying that
they're not clicking the button and the
local storage is still being cleared
when I go to check their their browsers
there's nothing in local storage but I
can't get it to clear on you know just
on its own again I can't recreate the
problem ok so I'm going to scroll down a
little bit I realize this is super small
yeah and I don't I don't know how to to
make this bigger except to I can zoom
into the site itself let's see if I can
zoom in here all right okay so the
uh you know just the zoom from the
touchpad on an eye and I like the iMac
magic touch pad works okay so we got a
little bigger here so I'm just going to
scroll you don't get like the real
feeling of scrolling I'm you know I'm
using my touchpad to scroll but we can
do some some clicking around okay so
that works yeah it's a little bit weird
to try to get the touch the touch stuff
down I keep like accidentally clicking
where I don't want to click or like
double clicking when I don't want to see
you Keith
maybe it's maybe it's because I zoomed
in let me zoom out again and see if I if
it's better
that's it yeah I can't win if we zoom in
the the clicking doesn't work so I love
it I'm going to scroll just quickly see
if I can find something that looks weird
and then if I do I'll scroll in on that
I want to try out the side knife and the
links so we'll try out this link okay
that worked that was cool that was
actually really fast okay
I'm going to take I'm actually going to
take the images out on mobile and just
have the title up here because they
won't look as good on mobile anyway and
I don't I don't want to kill people's
data plans by having them load images
when they're not necessary all right so
this these sections are actually going
to change so I'm not that worried about
it now I'm just I have some different
content I need to put in okay so these
cards look good on mobile everything
works these are still need to edit these
images to make them all square and the
same so right now I'm looking for items
that I I don't already know about the
neat change alright so I am interested
in this Oh
so that does work if let me zoom in here
and show you what's going on with this
so this gave me some problems this
morning
some people have super long titles and
they won't fit on the card so if they
were rapping below and adding another
line or sometimes two lines and then of
course the text was spilling out of the
bottom of this card so that the solution
would have been okay well let's just
make the card bigger but the problem is
I don't have great quality images to
work with so some of the images I have
are already less than 100 pixels by 100
pixels and so that's what I have here
these are 100 by hundred pixels so I
wanted to keep this and keep this 100
pixels in height so I settled on this
which I don't really like this solution
but I just don't have time to mess with
it more right now so I decided actually
on a horizontal scroll so you can scroll
over and see the rest of the title so on
larger screens this isn't an issue if
you think of another solution
somebody said truncate in the live chat
yeah I could possibly truncate it and
then when you click it let me show what
happens when you click when you click it
it comes up with a modal and gives you a
lot more information on the person so I
could possibly truncate and then have
the full title in the modal I've thought
about that I'll have to I don't know if
I'll have time to do that before we
launch but I'm going to put that on my
list I have a Trello board that's
keeping track of everything since I'm
zoomed in it's not letting me click out
there we go
so yeah that probably is going to be the
best thing just truncate this limited to
a certain number of characters and then
have the full one
be in the in the modal so I like that
advise yeah
actually that's that's what I did
overflow wise scroll somebody mentioned
change the font size I don't know the
fonts already small I could probably
make it smaller and get away with it at
least on on mobile there's there's just
a lot of overflow yeah I just I wish
some of these titles weren't quite so
long and it's not just one or two I mean
they're like quite a few of these that
have the super long titles so I am
eventually going to change this for now
this is probably how it's going to look
for launch since we're launching
tomorrow
let me check to make sure this works
oops maybe it's not working let's see am
I getting an error okay when I click
this it should open and it's not opening
on this phone let me refresh really
quick Wow oh that's not refresh that's
wish it looked like the refresh button
but it's really not okay so let me there
we go
let me find I've DS the refresh button
on the device just to see what's going
on okay that did work
let's go back I've put in like
client-side routing now I'm going to go
back into teams to see if it works so
the thing with client-side running if
you watch yesterday we went over
problems that you might have with jQuery
ok and I think this is an issue so
normally like I would initialize this
this click Handler to open these and the
document.ready function for jQuery but
it's not going to fire like if we're
just doing client-side routing and
there's no page refresh that function is
never going to fire again so the first
time it fires it'll be honest different
page it won't actually see those
sections so it won't have anything to
grab onto to to watch so what we have to
do is instead use like component
component did mount and then call it in
there so we pull it out of the document
already we put in a separate function
that's available globally and then we
call it from within our component when
it mounts so for some reason either I
forgot to do that for this or I didn't
it's not working so I need to add that
to the list so I'll show you how I keep
track of all these things so go over
here I have my Trello board so I'll just
put it over here and say um fix uh
section and look for routines
or teams with client-side routing and
I'm going to estimate that's going to
take one Pomodoro cycle that's what this
one is one 25-minute cycle okay somebody
else Humberto in the live chat says they
like the overflow ellipsis option yeah I
think that'll look that'll look ok we'll
probably end up going with that at some
point and all right so now that that bug
is it's tracked I'll get to it let's
let's move on I'm actually doing a
similar thing in another page so I
really want to see if it's working on
the other page and did I do it
differently on two different pages so
we're going to go over to courses and
let's see if it works here all right it
doesn't so I'm having the same issue on
both these pages so let's just go back
and add four teams and sort and courses
look good
all right so good thing this is a small
site we're already halfway through it
let's check out the events page see
what's going on here and not a lot we
have that's not bad maybe you could use
some padding changes but it it doesn't
look too bad
that's excellent or to read on that
background doesn't it this let me zoom
in maybe it's just the zoom so I will
try to zoom that was that what's broken
I been here for like the frame of the
word in YouTube okay oh the YouTube has
the YouTube embed messed this up see if
we can well it looks like a frozen my my
test here so maybe if I can't get this
to work again we'll switch and test
something else and then come back to
this one hmm
okay so that's frozen so let's let's
switch over now just for a minute and
I'll show you what let's check out we'll
do Windows 10 and let's check out
Internet Explorer 11
hopefully I won't have to worry about
supporting this for very much longer but
you can see I always have issues with in
an explorer 11 and mobile safari a lot
of the issues I know about beforehand so
I can I can edit my my code to make sure
that I fix them but you can see like I
was using flexbox to vertical line
things see it's not working in an
explorer 11 so you have to set up
alternate styles for internet explorer
11 some padding or something as we
scroll down at least this works and
let's go go to the home page see how
this is gone we have here okay so for
some reason the images aren't loading
off to check that out we can also we can
inspect but the inspector is not is not
great for this so you can't have to have
a lot of patience to inspect things when
you're working with older browsers it
said it may take a few minutes to start
I don't think I want to wait a few
minutes let's just this is good a team
now we're also using oh man look at that
Wow
so that scrollbar shows up because even
though we're not actually there's no
overflow that scrollbar so show them
that's no good all right I'm gonna have
to figure out if there's a way to hide
the scrollbar
and in and explore 11
and I don't want to spend too much time
I'm going to give myself one Pomodoro
session so one 25 minute period because
I if I can't find answer quickly I'll
probably it'll be a waste of time I
don't have all that time right now so I
kind of think that you can't hide these
but we'll see maybe maybe there's a way
I know you could do more with scroll
bars and like earlier versions of
Internet Explorer I remember making like
neon green colored scroll bars made like
15 years ago or so I think but I haven't
done that for a while and I don't know
if you can still do it let's go to the
news page and I just want to see if ok
so that's that routing that
parameterised routing that we had set up
it's definitely working and that's good
check our resources ok let's see I want
to see if these tabs will all the
scrolls like not great on this okay so
to see now this isn't working
so our our tabs are not working so let's
put this oops
so as expected Internet Explorer 11 is
giving us some some issues it doesn't
matter what you do it's your site's
never going to look as good and Explorer
11 as it will in more in modern browsers
I mean unless your site's really simple
it might look exactly the same but you
just can't take advantage of all the
same things that you normally would
would be able to in a modern browser so
we're not going to try to make this site
exactly the same the percentage of our
users that are on Internet Explorer 11
is really small if the issues were like
a really a big deal
like major functionality and menu is use
then you can just put a message I hate
to do this sometimes you have to you can
just pop a message up that detects the
browser and says you know hey if you're
using Internet Explorer you're not going
to have a great experience and then
provide a link to download you know some
newer browsers you don't even have to
write that code yourself there's already
some plugins that will just do it for
you so I'm going to check the live chat
real quick because I just wanted to show
you how I'm doing my testing I think
it's probably a little bit boring to
watch me go through here and just find
the errors and log them I'm not actually
fixing anything right now so I don't
want to spend a ton of time on it I'm
going to check the live chat quickly and
then I have a video another video from
syntax con with some advice for new
programmers and this this video is from
Kim Creighton shoes and excellent
speakers she was one of like the keynote
speakers at the conference and she's
actually not a coder but she speaks at a
ton of coding conferences and it was
great if you ever have a chance to see
her speak or watch one her videos I
recommend it it's like
she is nice like perspective on like
mentoring and company culture so it's
really really kind of cool stuff you
don't usually hear at tech conferences
okay let me check okay so I was getting
some people talking about the question I
asked at the beginning about auth0 and
in the emails and stuff
somebody says could there be a problem
with SMTP it's possible okay so I did
mention how to do the Android testing
and someone a live chat said it's the
tutorial on how to do that isn't the
responsive design for images course on
Udacity that's a free course I did go
through that course I recommend it I
learned a lot of stuff and a lot of the
things in there are still very relevant
even though the courses on a probably a
couple years old at this point I can't
remember when it came out officially but
the things that I learned in that course
are still still relevant someone
mentioned that they don't devote for
edge but it can be surprisingly
compatible yeah I had a lot of hope for
edge but it's just not a lot of people
aren't using it based on my analytics
for my sites it's there a small
percentage of people so that's why I
don't usually test things on edge it's
just not worth the time you know for
like 1% of the users
okay
okay someone mentioned materialized does
have the truncate class that's right I
forgot about that so there is a truncate
class the only I'll have to see how they
do it on with materialized I know there
was actually some like CSS truncation
that can go on but I don't know what the
browser support is but that's a good
that's a good point
I'm definitely going to going to check
that out if someone said that a slow
connection they couldn't see the title
bar sorry about that oh nice okay John
Hanson thank you very much he threw in
some of the CSS to be able to hide the
scroll bar so that definitely saves you
some time and I need some time savers
here so I really appreciate that
Patrick asked since you're estimating
pomodoro cycles to use a Pomodoro clock
while you work I do so I use a Pomodoro
clock oh let me show you the one I use I
use just a super simple web-based one
since this tomato timer so it's really
bare-bones I can do formula recession of
25 minutes your short break of five
minutes or long break of 10 I usually go
five minutes between cycles every four
cycles I do 10-minute break and I just
use this I like it you know runs right
in the browser so it's easy I tried out
some apps before that have more features
but usually I don't use any of the other
features so it just kind of clutters
things so using this right now at some
point I'd like to actually build my own
and customize it to exactly what I need
but I don't have time for that right now
maybe one day okay
Paul asks how is he sliding the full
screen
then right I'm on a Mac so yes so if
you're using the touchpad for your Mac
on a laptop or on a desktop and you use
three fingers and swipe it then that'll
that will change it so this is just a
three-finger swipe so it's super helpful
there is a way to make that work on
Windows it's you have to download a
program and set it up but I'm pretty
sure you can get a similar thing on
Windows I mean I don't know what you
obviously wouldn't probably would be
using a touchpad on Windows desktop but
there would be probably some type of key
I think there's a key combination like
control some there's some like key combo
that can do this on a Mac as well if you
don't want to use the the swipes okay so
get through the live chat if you have
anything else to ask go ahead I'll check
it one more time after I play this video
but let me get with the video going this
one's a little bit longer Kim had a lot
of good advice so this will be a few
minutes most of the other videos have
been like a minute or less so let me
bring in I'll bring this in and let's
make it fullscreen and let me let me
play this uh hopefully the audio is is
works there's at one point at the end of
this I think there's some background
noise so I hope you'll be able to hear
this and once again this is this is Kim
Creighton from syntax con hello everyone
I'm Tim Creighton and you can find my
Twitter it Khem creative board in this
ki elements are elección in one I am
here at six hack conference and one of
the things that I'm supposed to say
what's knowledge now exciting
first first of all Benton right I'm a
community engineer which means I help
community efforts I help people in the
technology space embrace change the
convoy elusive and diversity diverse
when it comes to people there is
backgrounds become a welcomed use like a
lot of writing podcasting or blogging
and speaking all those things are
community efforts so that's where I
excel um I also one aim a website and
select channel you find it on Twitter
edge J bar de vie mentoring and that's a
judoka Turing website so please join
there a lot of mentors on select I'll be
looking for people to help out and so
the what knowledge we had really
interesting I'm really interested in
eight and you are just really find it
very exciting a friend they I went to
their house and they had set it up in
their house and I spent two hours plan
is free of your system and by the time I
was done I was four ounce with but I've
had so much fun so I'm really interested
in seeing how that technology is that
advanced where it will be less about the
gear and more accessible to other people
how are you using it in just in everyday
life it will be very interesting to how
they I and a mini reality - I mean a are
augmented reality and virtual reality
are going to be used in just everyday
lives and so the one thing I would tell
newbies one of the pieces of Isis that's
become is all time is about mentoring so
everybody to become creative reading
it's virtually impossible for most
people who come to you they're very live
without on the mentor just for the
simple fact that this is like the Wild
West
there is no there is no defined path
winners if you want to be a doctor
there's a divine path if you want to be
a dentist there's a defined path if you
want to be educated in SIA pet if you
want to be a developer you go
taxi garbage gets to me and wake up
today dislike one of your developer and
can learn everything you need to learn
to be a developer so there's no more fun
iPad and without somebody more similar
to help guy what you're doing you often
find yourself and you've down this
rabbit holes or feeling really
discouraged and so mentors really help
but I'll give you some advice on how to
get an intern mentoring it's all the
mouth relationships so if one image
don't go to some lesson hey I need a
mentor this is what I want to learn
that's not how that works
oh you want somebody who's going to
invest in you and your success and that
only happens in the care that they care
about you know where they're going to
care about you is if they have a
relationship with you so five ways to
volunteer in your community a lot of
ways to ask my ways to ask how can I
help for you ask them to help you and
what happens is you'll find that they'll
go to you they'll see this or asking you
hey what are you working on how can I
help and then it becomes like them
you're advocating that's what you want
they want your first job to come from
your network you don't want to get your
first job because it was posted on the
website you want to be there so badly
about you before they of a full set job
you want to be the candidate before
their jobs even post it so the best way
to do that is to build your
relationships and get you over time
thank you
all right so hopefully that was helpful
to some of you I know I am I think a
mentor would be really helpful I didn't
really have I kind of had a mentor uh
but it was more in like in general like
digital marketing so search engine
optimization and SUV by copywriting and
things so I never really had like a
programmer mentor and even now I you
know I already have a full-time job
doing this I can still see the value and
having a mentor and I've been able to be
somewhat of a mentor to to some some of
the students here who are interested in
programming and it's it's awesome
I mean you know I can see whenever I
help people out make it they get through
things a lot faster than I get through
things because I can point them to a
resource that I know is good I know the
problems that they'll probably run into
before they do
so whereas it would take me a long time
and I would work through some resources
that weren't very helpful before I found
the right ones you know if if you're
mentoring someone you can help them get
through that faster or if you're seeking
out a mentor they can help you get
through that faster so you just don't
waste your time going down dead-end
paths people that have been doing this
for longer have a much better idea of of
the big picture and I can can direct you
to where you need to go and what you
need to learn so good advice from from
Kim and I don't see all right we don't
have any other questions in the live
chat so I'm going to get to work
tomorrow we're going to launch this site
so the video that might already be
launched by the time I do the video
tomorrow I'm hoping it is maybe I'll
have to just stay up late tonight and
tomorrow and get it launched tomorrow
night but hopefully it'll be ready
enough to launch thanks for all your
help I know you all put in some some
really good advice too you know I asked
a lot of questions of you this time
around and I really really appreciate
that hopefully when I do these live
streams we can learn from each other and
your projects will get better and so
will mine thanks so much for watching
and I'll be back tomorrow